bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 1er
décembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de cette fuite le
journal comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré à de
nos invités mais aussi des journalistes
de la rédaction
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de cette édition journée
internationale de lutte contre le sida
le nombre de contaminations et en os
les initiatives se multiplient pour
sensibiliser la population
nous irons dans un lycée de trappes qui
a décidé d'utiliser l'art pour
interpeller les élèves sur ce sujet et
réduire sa consommation d'énergie l'
agence locale de l'énergie du climat de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance pour la
troisième fois ce défi aux familles à
partir du 1er décembre et durant cinq
mois adopter les bons gestes nous en
parlerons avec notre invité en plateau
et puis en politique à quelques jours du
premier tour des régionales le point sur
la campagne d'europe écologie les verts
les écologistes pour l'instant pour
l'instant crédité d'un peu moins de 7%
d'intentions de vote en ile de france et
aujourd'hui 1er décembre journée
internationale de lutte contre le sida
et ce constat l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms fait état de 142 mille
nouveaux diagnostics du jamais vu depuis
l'apparition de la maladie en europe
dans les années 1980 je vous propose
d'écouter jérôme andré président de
l'association hf prévention il était
l'invité de notre journal vendredi
dernier
depuis deux trois ans est plutôt à la
hausse en sachant que effectivement ça
c'est les statistiques officielles
ministère nous on voit qu'il ya une
reprise de l'activité notamment sur le
dépistage et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle d'avoir une reprise d'activité
alors que les autotests arrive ça veut
dire que les gens vont pouvoir
maintenant se faire dépister plus il y a
effectivement de de dépistage plus on
trouve les personnes qui s'ignore ce
camp moyen de 30000 personnes s'ignorent
mais c'est pas une bonne nouvelle de
voir les chiffres repartir à la hausse
depuis deux trois ans et salines à la
vigilance effectivement une baisse de la
vigilance c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour le vih c'est pas non plus une bonne
nouvelle pour les infections
sexuellement transmissibles et encore
moins pour les hépatites
d'ailleurs l'année prochaine on va être
habilité pour les trucks donc les tests
rapides d'orientation au dépistage pour
l'hépatite c notamment et sur le même
sujet cela est arrêté à présent au lycée
louis-blériot attrape les élèves se sont
mobilisés pour réaliser une fresque
géante dans la cour de l'établissement
pour l'occasion l'artiste parisien
jitrois est venu leur apporter son
soutien mais aussi ses conseils pendant
deux jours les élèves se sont succédé
malgré le mauvais temps pour apporter à
leur manière la couleur contribution au
sidaction un reportage signé ou de
gamelles et jérémy quesada
des courbes qui apparaissent et
s'enchevêtrent au fur et à mesure autour
d'un grand ruban
c'est le travail de l'artiste j 3 qui
réalise deux gigantesques peinture à la
craie dans les rues de la capitale
aujourd'hui il est venu à trappes au
lycée louis blériot pour partager
étendre son art au profit du sidaction
je ne sais jamais où je vais c'est
vraiment si je suis dans l'instant
j'essaye de ne sais pas je pense à rien
mais simplement je suis au moment sur
mon présent donc je me laisse ça vient
tout seul c'est plus le corps finalement
qui parle c'est pour ça que mes courbes
sont assez ample parce que finalement
c'est tout le corps qui participe quand
je dessine pendant deux jours les élèves
de l'établissement se sont succédé
autour de cette oeuvre apportant chacun
leur contribution
ici pas de limites ni de règles textes
ou des seins
chacun choisit son moyen d'expression
j'ai choisi d'écrire sida mais en
faisant des graffitis
j'ai dessiné plusieurs coeurs parce que
bah si l'action avant tout c'est de
l'amour
moi je pense que c'est pratique plutôt
de dessiner que gueule dit comme ça ça
mon plus qu' on est debout contre le
sida un moyen d'expression libre pour la
bonne cause une sorte de cadavre exquis
auquel tout le monde participe
on a travaillé sur le motif de
l'entremêlement du ruban et puis sur les
motifs qu'on reconnaît par rapport au
sida dont que ça va être des
préservatifs ça va être des serins que
ça peut être le symbole de l'homme et de
la femme
et puis en plus ce travail de j 3 ça
raconte l'art dans l'espace public ce
qu'on a travaillé aussi avec les élèves
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
rejoignent et puis voilà pour une
journée de prévention comme ça et puis
les sensibiliser au sida y est assez
risqué
est ce que ça implique sensibiliser les
élèves parlent art un art lui très
éphémère mais pas les valeurs qu'il
véhicule
cent cinquante mille personnes vivent
aujourd'hui avec le vih en france dont
30 mille at il ignore le ministère de la
santé lance aujourd'hui une campagne de
communication courage en tout les
français à se faire dépister que ce soit
en laboratoire dans les centres de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit ou en
achetant un autotest en pharmacie des
autotests qui sont disponibles depuis le
15 septembre
mais selon la société qui les
commercialise il ne s'en rendrait en
moyenne que 2 par mois et par officine
nous avons voulu savoir ce que vous en
pensez c'est notre question du jour au
regard des basses et moi je pense à peu
plus de rassurer qu'autre chose et aider
je pense pas je pense que le principal
c'est de se protéger et qu une seule
solution donc je pensais plus pour
rassurer qu'autre chose quoi oui puisque
beaucoup de gens qui ne savent pas
qu'ils sont porteurs du virus ont
l'accès en toute confidentialité
à la question qui peuvent se poser le
fait que chacun puisse effectivement
savoir très facilement
et puis à titre privé dans un contexte
plutôt privé avoir les résultats fiables
ou est constitué ça va permettre aux
éventuels patients atteints du sida
supposé atteints du sida
d'anciens dépister avoir éventuellement
une certitude de quoi qui sont qu'ils
ont cette pathologie tout simplement et
comme à chaque mardi dans le journal
nous parlons à présent un politique
bonsoir wilfried alors dernière ligne
droite avant le vote de dimanche
bonsoir florame la campagne touche
effectivement à sa fin puisque dimanche
les yeux nous devons livrer leur verdict
et ce soir il est question d'europe
écologie les verts europe ecologie les
verts et qui n'a pas fait l'union avec
le parti socialiste tout comme le front
de gauche les écologistes ont décidé de
partir seul pour ce premier tour
pourtant c'est bien un bilan commun que
défendent ces différentes formations
elles ont siégé ensemble à la région ile
de france
mettons ce point de côté je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite emmanuelle cosse
elle était présente dans les yvelines
la semaine dernière pour un meeting
départemental ou plutôt une réunion
d'information la campagne était
officiellement entre parenthèses en
raison des
attentat en tout cas sur le papier car
ce qu'il agace en ce moment c'est le
temps de parole au sein des différents
médias la réalité c'est que l'équité est
une juste farce qui nous est racontée
elle n'est pas respectée
y compris la semaine dernière elle a
totalement volet volé en éclats et c'est
un problème et pour les écologistes et
pour plein d'autres personnes il faut le
dire tel que c'est c'est qu'aujourd'hui
certains partis trust la place
médiatique et pour nous c'est un
problème en effet c'est une difficulté
et nous aimerions vraiment que en fait
l'ensemble des chaînes publiques et en
particulier services publics travaillent
différemment de ce point de vue là
europe ecologie les verts dans les
sondages c'est un peu moins de 7% juste
derrière le front de gauche et c'est peu
et dans les yvelines en particulier ça
pourrait être encore moins ça n'inquiète
pas pour autant mounir satouri c'est la
tête de liste civile oui les yvelines
sont une terre des missions et on a déjà
vu au dernier compte annales des scores
importants dans les milieu péri urbain
qui avaient pu faire le front national
ça atteignez parfois 25 ça c'est allé
même jusqu'à 30%
face à cela nous on va faire campagne on
va faire sur nos thèmes on va faire sur
l'égalité territoriale
on va faire sur le droit pour tous les
franciliens la mobilité le droit à la
relocalisation d'une économie qui
répondent en termes d'emploi aux
franciliens mais c'est vrai qu'on est
dans un timing très court timing très
court après les attentats bien sûr alors
concernant les propositions europe
écologie a pour sujet phare la qualité
de l'air la philosophie de notre projet
c'est que l'écologie soit au pouvoir
pour la région pour changer d'ère résume
emmanuelle cosse l avance un plan
d'actions de 3 milliards pour en finir
avec la pollution de l'air justement et
pour que nous puissions enfin laisser
nos voitures au garage
je pense que pour beaucoup de gens qui
vivent dans les yvelines
il ya des évolutions que nous portons en
matière d'accès aux de renforcement de
lignes de bus de renforcement de lignes
pas omnibus mais deux lignes de trains
plus directe qui pourrait leur permettre
à terme d'abandonner leur voiture dans
des gares et donc de pouvoir rejoindre
leurs emplois essentiellement à paris ou
dans les hauts-de-seine
de manière plus rapide parce que au-delà
de
du temps passé dans les embouteillages
et aussi le stress est aussi le coup il
ya aussi la fatigue et aussi la
pollution parce que quand on conduit un
véhicule on est aussi victime de la
pollution donc cessé d un jeu évidemment
pour nous très important et c'est vrai
qu'une partie des yvelines a été pas
assez intégrés en fait dans le
développement des transports
voilà pour cet axe principal mais vous
l'avez compris le problème pour europe
ecologie les verts s'est donc d'exister
au milieu des sujets nationaux en marge
des formations plus importante avec les
attentats le 13 novembre et puis
l'ouverture de la coop aussi hier lundi
et pourtant l'argument environnemental
avec la coop 21 devrait leur permettre
de mieux faire passer leurs ide en ce
moment oui mais si l'on en croit les
sondages on l'a vu tout à l'heure cette
course on sait peu alors forcément on
pense déjà à la suite si au début de la
campagne les critiques envers le ps
était sévère aujourd'hui les écologistes
ouvre grand la porte au ralliement pour
le second tour c'est presque une
question de survie d'ailleurs on se
souvient il ya quelques semaines
plusieurs cadres du parti avait décidé
de claquer la porte dont le sénateur
jean vincent placé
on a toujours été clair son sujet
le premier tour était fait pour
présenter notre projet et faire entendre
nos propositions et le deuxième taux
notre alliance allait avec les forces de
gauche et on saura se rassembler comme
on l'avait prévu depuis le début comme
on l'a toujours dit le soir du premier
tour bien évidemment merci wilfried on
vous retrouve après ce journal pour le
7-8 politique avec les candidats têtes
de liste de nous citoyens et front
national et puis à lundi prochain dès
18h en direct sur ce plateau les
résultats les analyses du premier tour
le lendemain mardi à débat entre les
représentants des listes qualifiées en
ile de france
autre sujet à présent agriculture
vendredi et samedi à saint quentin en
yvelines la communauté d'agglomération
et l'association terre et cités ont
présenté aux acteurs locaux leur
diagnostic de l'agriculture locale à
saint quentin en yvelines à partir d'une
étude un état des lieux de l'agriculture
le calloch a été réalisé pour il a pour
objectif d'identifier les conditions du
développement de filières agricoles de
proximité
les images sont signés fanny bourdon
certains les connaissent bien d'autres
les découvre les jardins partagés de la
verrière font partie des 1035 écart
cultiver de saint quentin en yvelines
ce samedi l'agglomération et
l'association terre et cités ont emmené
les acteurs locaux et associatifs dans
plusieurs lieux de culture afin
d'illustrer le potentiel agricole du
territoire et ses bénéfices pour les
habitants il ya une multitude
d'associations qui font ce travail sur
l'agriculture urbaine avec des petits
bacs des petits potagers etc
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
vraiment de sensibiliser les populations
à une en alimentation de meilleure
qualité et locales et ensuite petit à
petit les habitants en viennent à
consommer des produits locaux
la produit à plus grande échelle sur les
exploitations du territoire des données
établies à la suite d'une étude menée
entre 2014 et 2015 conjointement par
l'agglomération et l'association
à la veille de l'agrandissement du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
une réalité qui doit être prise en
compte on s'est aussi rendu compte que
les exploitants étaient prêts à aller
vers des diversifications
alors peut-être pas leur génération mais
la génération suivante à condition
qu'ils soient que la fonctionnalité des
exploitations agricoles soit préservé
voire peut-être même amélioré au 1er
janvier 2016 les surfaces agricoles vont
doubler et dépasser les 2400 hectares
enfin d'ici 2022 il faudra définir un
projet pour la zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière du
plateau de saclay elle comprend une
partie de la commune de guyancourt et la
coop 21 qui se tient actuellement au
bourget donne des idées aux défenseurs
de la nature et de l'environnement
l'association de sauvegarde des étangs
de la minière a planté près de 200
jeunes jeunes arbres samedi pour
reboiser un peu cette zone anciennement
touristique encadrés par luan est bien
évidemment c'est une initiative assez
rare les précisions avec mélanie potter
aux étangs de la minière la nature
continue de reprendre ses droits
mais parfois elle a besoin d'un peu dead
l'association de sauvegarde des étangs
de laminaires a donc sorti pioche et
piqué notre rôle c'est de protéger la
forêt de la minière et de faire en sorte
qu'elle quelle soit valorisée donc cet
espace qui est ténue depuis l'année
dernière qui est abandonné depuis une
bonne dizaine d'années va revivre
on espère grâce à nous
et grâce aux plans qui vont qui vont
pousser dans les prochaines années géré
par l'office national des forêts les
étangs de la minière accueillait une
base nautique dans les années 60 la
forêt dans les neuf ans en pleine rue
naturalisation l'intervention humaine et
exceptionnelles arrêtant de la minière
disons que c'est à l'avancement de
des opérations de renouvellement des
peuplements eux
en règle générale on essaye de voir de
la régénération naturelle de faire
parler la matière naturelle que puisque
peut nous donner la forêt c'est 90% des
régénérations de renouvellement des
peuplements il n'ya que branco d'échecs
où on
on envisage de replanter ce samedi ce
sont 150 chaînes 25 charme et 25 points
qui ont été plantés
il ne reste plus qu'à laisser le temps
aux faire son travail et nous restons
sur l'environnement pour la troisième
année avec de saint quentin en yvelines
à nîmes l'opération défi familles à
énergie positive sur le territoire du
sud des yvelines
pour nous en parler ce soir en plateau
avec new frontier le directeur de la
lègue de 50 ans edwin bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors tout d'abord qu'est-ce que ce défi
familles à énergie positive dit nous on
puisse alors le plus le défi famille
énergie positive il a pour objectif de
rassembler des familles en équipe de
façon à réduire de 8% c'est sa facture
d'énergie sur une période de dix verres
donc entre le 1er décembre et le 30
avril de manière conviviale voilà l'idée
c'est de que les familles s'empare du
sujet pour réduire leur consommation
d'énergie chez elle alors concrètement
comment ça se passe est ce que c'est
vrai une famille a vécu des parents des
enfants on peut se détendre à plusieurs
fins il ya des règles un peu sur une
autre participant non alors en fait
l'idée c'est que toute famille peut
participer il faut juste avoir habité on
va dire un an dans son logement puisque
on compare les consommations d'énergie
de cet hiver avec l'hiver précédent pour
pouvoir faire des comparaisons et voir
si effectivement on a réduit sa
consommation d'énergie mais sinon tout
famille est bienvenu on peut être une
personne seule en fait une famille avec
des enfants sans enfant n'y a pas de
problème tout le monde est bienvenu
et puis donc les familles en fête se
réunissent en équipe de façon à pouvoir
faire ça de façon plus conviviale
organiser des soirées soirées qu'on
appelle tu perds watts
donc l'idée c'est voilà d'échangés entre
entre les familles d'échanger sur les
bons trucs voilà comment moi j'arrive à
réduire ma consommation d'énergie alors
justement comment font-elles pour
réduire leur consommation il faut
peut-être faire attention à l'eau voici
est un royaume et les nerfs mais un
certain nombre d'autres choses il ya
plein de choses en fait on distribue à
chaque famille un guide dans lequel il
ya 100 éco gestes donc il y en a
forcément qu'on fait pas alors des
choses simples par exemple réduire la
température de son logement la nuit on
n'a pas besoin d'être autant chauffer
quand on dort voilà pas mettre de plats
chauds dans le frigidaire par exemple
parce que le réfrigérateur c'est un des
premiers postes de consommation
d'électricité dans logement donc voilà
faire attention à ces choses-là prendre
une douche et au à la place
drain bas par exemple évidemment alors
une douche courte parce que ce qu'il
vous reste une demi heure sous la douche
c'est pas sûr qu'on y gagne
voilà donc un peu toutes ces choses là
est ce qu'il ya des écogestes vraiment
faim très facile à faire auxquelles on
ne pense pas ou qui ne sont il n'y a pas
beaucoup de communication de chiens en
fait il ya tellement de choses possible
que je dirais voilà ya forcément des
choses quoi auquel on pense pas mais il
ya des choses assez on entend assez
souvent ces genres de baisser la
température d'un degré dans son logement
ça fait faire un peu pas 7% en économie
d'énergie donc rien que ça voilà on y
est presque 8% donc voilà des choses ça
c'est des choses qui marchent bien
donc c'est la troisième édition est
organisé l'opération qui est un succès
vous avez de plus en plus de personnes
qui s'inscrivent alors bon c'est la
troisième édition la première on avait
cinquante cinq familles qui sont allés
jusqu'au bout du défi deuxième 2ème
saison ça a été un petit peu plus dur on
avait 37 familles qui sont arrivés au
bout et puis là cette année on est
content puisqu'on a déjà aujourd'hui on
à 63 familles qui sont engagés dans dix
équipes
et puis c'est pas encore fini puisqu'on
peut encore s'inscrire jusqu'à samedi
donc voilà si vous êtes intéressé
n'hésitez pas à ça est-ce que vous avez
des voitures justement sur ces familles
qui se sont inscrits est ce que
maintenant elles ont peut-être changé
leur mode de vie par rapport justement à
ces défis alors changer de mode de vie
c'était un grand moment parce que l'idée
c'est pas de complètement chamboulé
c'est juste de faire un peu attention
voilà de faire des écogestes le
principal c'est de faire les choses sans
perte de confort de voilà de faire les
choses petit qui nous fait que l'on
souhaite faire
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à
faire des économies d'énergie a pas
besoin de complètement chamboulé sa fin
à son beau gosse que justement parfois
on s'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup de
travaux à faire pour faire des non c'est
pas le cas et en l'occurrence l'aller on
joue vraiment sur ce qu'on appelle la
sobriété énergétique c'est à dire c'est
que les comportements la façon de voilà
d'agir au jour le jour ce défi là il
faut pas faire de travaux justement il
faut pas faire de grosses dépenses au
contraire on va on va gagner de l'argent
puisque en moyenne les familles gagnent
à peu près 200 euros sur leurs charges
de 2 d'énergie voilà sur la non pas par
moi quand même sur l'année vous avez
voulu mettre en place cette façon qu'il
ya trois ans est ce que c'est
initiative comme celle ci se développe
partout en france il ya vraiment un
mouvement dynamique par rapport à ça oui
tout à fait donc nous on en est à notre
troisième édition mais en fait au niveau
national le défi a démarré il ya sept
ans donc il ya certains certains
territoires qu'ils ont déjà organisé
depuis depuis sept ans aujourd'hui il ya
à peu près six mille familles qui sont
engagés en france pour cette troisième
édition dans leur sac allemand à kehl a
comme feu 21 voix là se passe en ce
moment au bourget du coup ce défi prend
une dimension un petit peu spéciale est
ce que vous pensez que voilà c'est des
petits gestes comme ça il faut plus en
parler que peut-être des grandes
décisions et qui ont plus d'impact
au moins c'est clair que les grandes
décisions c'est une chose mais c'est pas
ça qui fait réduire la consommation
d'énergie c'est vraiment chacun qui peut
à son niveau
ben en faisant des petits gestes
effectivement arriver à réduire la
consommation d'énergie donc du coup à
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ailleurs ce défi en fait lié à
la base on a parlé de 8% d'économies
d'énergie c'est l'objectif qu'on cherche
à atteindre et ses 8 % correspondent
effectivement aux 8 % de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre liées
au protocole de kyoto donc voilà
aujourd'hui on arrive dans la suite du
protocole de kyoto avec cette coop 21
donc on est complètement dans le sujet
oui est ce qu'on pensait que le
gouvernement doit faire un petit peu
plus pour sensibiliser justement à les
gens à ces économies d'énergie qu'il
peut faire pour rallier la planète alors
sensibiliser en fait ça passe par part
du local c'est à dire c'est pas
tellement au niveau national qu on peut
sensibiliser on a besoin d'avoir des
acteurs locaux des associations qui
relaie en fait tous et toutes ces
initiatives et qui permettent de voilà
d'aider les gens à effectivement réduire
et à les sensibiliser à cette thématique
et pour vous localement vous avez tant
des crêtes décisions spécifiques ou
peut-être des budgets qui peuvent être
voté pour ça et qui pourraient découler
justement de cette comme 21 alors en
local je ne sais pas si ça sera
directement liée à la coupe 21 mais de
toute façon oui les politiques de
comment dirais-je des collectivités un
soulier enfin
on a une loi sur la transition
énergétique a été votée il ya pas
longtemps dans lequel il est dit
vraiment que les collectivités locales
sont les acteurs numéro un pour
l'animation territoriale et pour
justement faire que les la fin de
l'énergie soit ou de moins en moins
consommer sur nos territoires
et puis quand on consomme de l'énergie
renouvelable vous pensez qu'il faut
faire quels types d'actions fin ce genre
d'action ou peut-être d'autres que vous
menez pour mobiliser les gens sur le
sujet y avait d'autres choses à faire
encore alors effectivement donc il ya le
volet sobriété énergétique c'est le défi
familles à énergie positive
à côté de ça on peut on doit aussi
réduire sa consommation d'énergie en
utilisant de manière plus efficace
l'énergie et donc par exemple on peut
isoler son logement ça c'est un moyen
aussi de réduire sa consommation
d'énergie
donc nous à l'aller qu'effectivement on
fait du conseil auprès des particuliers
les gens peuvent venir nous voir
gratuitement on est indépendant et une
association on pourra donner les
avantages des inconvénients des
différentes solutions pour isoler son
logement et réduire ainsi sa
consommation d'énergie alors je le
rappelle l'opération débute aujourd'hui
comment fait-on pour s'inscrire on a
jusqu'à samedi
voilà le mieux c'est d'aller sur le
notre site internet donc double
www.nrj.fr jce à ses jambes à dakola
voila.fr et celui direct.com voilà donc
là vous aurez toutes les informations
pour vous inscrire
et donc après vous pouvez aller sur le
site dédié en fait aux défis familles à
énergie positive également pour avoir
toutes les informations pour la dsit et
pas à relever ce défi ce dingo geste
pour la planète merci beaucoup franck
sentiers d'avoir répondu à nos questions
j'ai parlé maintenant musique
ce week-end se tenait le concours
international du jeune flûtiste picot et
flûtes et est à l'honneur pendant deux
jours à l'espace camille après une année
d'interruption le concours retrouver la
commune de maurepas plus de 120 jeunes
flûtistes était au rendez vous un
reportage filmé la nouveauté
l'air ne visait sans doute pas inconnu
fantaisie sur la traviata de verdi
c'est la finale de piccolo les
concurrentes une dizaine de minutes pour
faire la différence
des candidats de premier cycle comme
d'excellence l'école de cuite française
est très renommée à travers le monde et
donc en fait on se doit de continuer à
honorer tout ce qui nous a été donné
jusqu'à présent ce qui nous permet de
mettre en avant les futurs jeunes
talents qui fera mesure des années
puisque elle encourait vingt ans
deviennent des professionnelles comme
notre président de jury cette année
adriana ferreira des futurs
professionnels peut-être le concours
rassemble chaque année des flûtistes de
toute la france mais aussi
internationaux venant assez d'espagne
d'allemagne ou encore du japon à l'image
d'adriana ferreira lauréate en 2010 elle
est aujourd'hui membre de l' orchestre
national de france
la route est donc un instrument l'amusé
c'est toujours le plus important et s'il
est donc politiquement il faut
rechercher de bonnes bases techniques
mais après c'est la musique la plus
important exigence était le maître mot
que ce soit du côté du jury comme celui
des candidats 129 jeunes flûtistes se
sont affrontés durant deux jours sur des
variations technique et pour finir les
églises de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines organise cette
semaine
l'événement l'église en fait à
l'approché de noël les parois se
mobilisent pour redonner un sens
religieux à cette fête familiale metz
évangélisation et porte-à-porte sont au
programme samedi
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
les jeunes de l'église ont organisé un
flashmob les précisions au micro de fans
bruyants pendant une semaine c'est notre
temps paroisse en fait
noël approche on se dit qu'en ce moment
ce tant d'événements douloureux pour
notre pays
on a besoin de retrouver le sens de noël
un moment festif un moment de joie
la venue dans le monde du prince de la
paix et donc notre paroisse catholique
la de saint quentin saint victor eh bien
on organise une semaine d'événements
avec des concerts des rencontres on va à
la rencontre des gens les invités à
différents moments et donc on a des
jeunes qui sont venus nous aider pour
cette semaine
qui sont ceux que vous voyez ici et
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant wilfried richy pour le cdh fit
politique quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à la même heure pour une nouvelle
édition du journal en direct je vous
souhaite donc une très bonne soirée
m